words are arranged in different ways in
different languages and even in
different types of sentences in the same
language this gets called word order
there are three components that we look
at when we describe the basic word order
of a language the subject word the
object word and the verb once we
identify a subject a verb and an object
we can consider their arrangement many
many languages have the basic word order
subject verb object in other words the
subject comes first followed by a verb
and the verb is followed by its object
another common configuration is subject
object verb other configurations are
even less common basic word order
doesn't tell us everything about the
structure of a sentence
it just gives us some gist of how
sentences in a language may be arranged
also many languages don't strictly stick
to their basic word order hence the word
basic a great example is English English
has the basic word order subject verb
object
it's an SVO language yet when we ask a
question with the verb e or in some
cases the verb have we switch the word
order the traditional way of describing
that is to say that we invert the verb
and it's subject to ask a question in
other words it's argued that the word
order of English questions with the verb
be switch is to verb subject object so
we say are you happy were you there
we're inverting this subject and the
verb this explanation brings up the
concept of inversion in other words
switching the place of words but
consider a different explanation for the
same change this one will use the
concept of movement or just move in this
case we're performing an operation in
which we move one of the words so
instead of saying that we invert the
words B and the subject in our you there
we're just moving our before the subject
and this will give us basically the same
result by performing a different
operation instead of switching places
we're just moving one of the words
and a final concept to consider with
respect to word order is the adjunct an
adjunct is optional material more words
that you can add since it's optional it
modifies I asked the question were you
there but I could add more material were
you there on Thursday and even more
material were you there at the school on
Thursday we can call those extra pieces
adjuncts take time to make sure you
understand this lesson in the previous
two lessons in the grammar of sentences
next time we'll use all of this basic
understanding to start building
grammatical rules
you